welcome everyone
hello so I'm it's like who's that up
there with Lee I my name is patty
sellers
I just asked Lee how long we've known
each other Lee just celebrated her 10th
anniversary at Fortune magazine I have
been there for 33 years so I have known
seems like I've known you for at least
20 years it feels that way it does feel
this way but it doesn't feel old
this feels like we're in our living room
yes it does so Lee is my closest friend
at fortune so full disclosure this is
not but see that still ask me tough
questions this is not gonna be that edgy
or challenging it's up to you to ask the
challenging question it's the really
tough questions so I was very flattered
when I was in the middle of the Airbnb
story when Lee asked me if she would do
this tonight gave me incentive to finish
the book is great we expect you all to
read it I was a big fan of Lee's first
book the end and is it the end of the
suburbs or end of the suburbs see the
end of the suburbs and that is about the
movement from the suburbs to the cities
of people companies and money and so
this Airbnb story was kind of a natural
for you as a follow up how natural
wasn't and how did it come along yeah a
lot of people ask me that and first of
all just say thank you to the core club
for having us here tonight in this
lovely room in this lovely setting it's
really wonderful so thank you and thank
you patty for saying
so the way I came to this idea I mean
first of all I do like documenting very
big seismic trends and the consumer
zeitgeist that are rooted in economic
data so that's how what led me to write
about this we're moving away from the
suburbs which is like a giant idea
because the suburbs sort of were America
for so long on so many levels and so
many years ago back in 2009 at fortune
one of my job's is to edit the 40 under
40 list and we're always getting these
breathless pitches of these companies oh
god they're gonna be the next big thing
they have to be on your list and so you
get a little bit you know used to these
companies that sound like they're the
next big thing and the next year they're
nothing and so somebody came to me and
said oh no everyone's talking about this
company Airbnb and I sort of rolled my
eyes and I said this was probably in
2009 and I said you know I've used
HomeAway comm for years I've used VRBO
dot-com this is these tech companies
think they can just take an old idea and
reissue out and out into the marketplace
and you know I just sort of dismissed
them and then very quickly after that it
became clear that they were growing
incredibly incredibly fast and they were
clearly struck a chord and then shortly
after that our colleagues asked me to
interview the CEO Brian Chesky at one of
our conferences fortune brain storm tech
and that was when I really dug into the
numbers to get ready for that interview
and I just I was pretty shocked by what
I saw and I learned a lot more about the
back story and I just and then when I
met him and just sort of interviewed him
I was really struck by him and the
journey that he had been on and this was
back in 2012 from basically being an art
school student not knowing anything
about business to now running this
company that was controversial
disruptive huge successful you know
beloved by consumers hated by regulators
and all this stuff and so I was really
struck by that and then it just
continued it just sort of exponentially
like three more hockey sticks from there
they just can't the company is doubled
every year including last year almost
for nine years and so and I just saw the
way the consumer had really seized on
what they had offered and
it was this sort of cultural touchstone
and I just thought all of that plus all
the things that Canon go and have gone
wrong on the platform all the drama I
mean there was just so much there and
these three total Outsiders had
accidentally stumbled upon this I
thought the whole thing was sort of a
business tale for the ages and there
hadn't been a book done on it before and
my editor Rick wolf who's here
really really wanted it so that always
helps so I met Rick your editor and was
it a matter of Rick coming to you are
you going to Rick and say I had to do
this combination I can't totally
remember I mean I had an agent and we
you know I I knew I had access to the
company and to Brian Chesky I knew that
he trusted me a lot and I knew that
there was a book to be written about
this company and I thought I was in a
pretty good position to do it and I also
thought it was a natural follow-on to my
last book and it's the kind of things I
like to write about but I'm not a
Silicon Valley reporter I'm not one of
the people there are many people who
cover whose job it is is to cover these
companies day in and day out and they
know every single wrinkle and every
single move and every single venture
capitalist and I am NOT one of those
people so I was sort of coming at it
from this like 30,000 foot angle and
from a more of a cultural and change
angle I guess who here has used Airbnb
who here hasn't not many
that's amazing used a trick with it who
has had a great experience with Airbnb
who's had a bad experience
interesting interesting okay you can
well by the way I mean when I came in
here early tonight I mean there's two
people in the audience who are building
businesses around the concept of Home
Sharing and Airbnb there's one person
who's a super host there's one person
Jennifer who's selling the books is has
booked up her next trip all on Airbnb
she just told me I mean it's it's
everywhere it has that you bring it up
at a cocktail party and it's it's
everyone has a thought about it or has
used it and it also goes to show it
started out as for Millenia
thing and now it's it's really everyone
I mean it's they've got luxury they've
got everything so anyway so you went
into this knowing a lot about the
company knowing Brian Chesky getting
Brian's trust once you got in deep what
surprised you a couple things surprised
me one is I thought I knew the company I
thought oh I have a running started
early written I did a big feature on him
and I just when you write a book there's
just I just got in to the process that's
like I don't know anything but a couple
things surprise me one is how incredibly
hard it was for them to get it off the
ground and I mean I sort of knew that
but I didn't really know the full extent
I mean the company very many times came
very close to dying and not getting off
the ground because for a couple reasons
I mean nobody thought this was a good
idea people thought this was crazy
people thought what do you are you
kidding yourself strangers are gonna
stay with other strangers one of Brian
Chesky is biggest mentors who he admired
so much the first time he told it about
told him about it he said he looked at
him and he said I hope you that's not
the only thing you're working on and
Chris Sacca who's a very well-known
investor there's many many famous
investors who said no to this and
basically missed out on hundreds of
millions of dollars and Chris Sacca was
one of them and he said that he pulled
them aside one day and he said you guys
somebody's gonna get murdered in one of
these houses and you're gonna have blood
in your hands I'm not going near this I
mean this is the reaction of everyone
and so they had no money they had they
couldn't make it they launched three
times they said if you launch and no one
notices Just Lunch again and then launch
again they just kept watching because
they no one was using this service and
they hustled they had a pitch deck at
one point and they had it all ready to
go and then the night before the
presentation with an investor who
actually did agreed to meet with them
they had a conversation with Sam Altman
who isn't another entrepreneur out in
Silicon Valley and they showed it to him
and he said you guys people don't want
to hear CMS investors want to see B's
all their numbers were millions he said
investors want to see billions so they
changed all the numbers to billions
and and it was to the co-founders Brian
and Joe Gebbia and the third one napola
sharklet our zyk who was very practical
and very serious and very he's much more
by the book and he said he took one look
at it and he say it's a two billion and
he said you guys the BS factor is just
going to go wild they're gonna know that
that's not true and they said okay okay
and they they the next day they are in
the presentation and they get to that
slide and they had changed it to twenty
billion you know
renegades and they hustled and you know
it worked so what is the difference
between air B&B and HomeAway and these
other companies that came along first
that's a really good question and there
there are some really important
differences that I wasn't aware of when
I you know dismiss them summarily one is
that you know a lot of a lot of
discussion is made over the fact that
two of the three co-founders are
designers so there are three co-founders
Brian Chesky Joe Gebbia and Napal
charvak as I mentioned Brian and Joe
were graduates of the Rhode Island
School of Design
they were industrial design majors and
they were you know design people and
part of the reason they couldn't get
funded was because that didn't fit the
mold of what Silicon Valley was looking
for they weren't a coder from Harvard or
to PhD dropout two PhDs not robots from
Stanford in the Google mold so RISD
nobody had ever heard of that so but the
way they designed the site really did
have a make a difference in that you
know it was it was very user friendly
they made the photography a very big
deal so that when you look through the
pages it was sort of like looking at
magazine pictures of real estate and
they offered free photography for
everybody so that was a big difference
they they set up a review system which
is sort of meant to be a natural checks
and balances system that keeps everybody
honest
everyone's reviewed both the travelers
and the people who are renting out their
homes so that was a that was something
another thing was that it was urban a
lot of those other sites were almost
exclusively vacation second home rentals
they were in beach towns in mountain
towns and they function more like
classified ad market places whereas
Airbnb were the sort of self-contained
community and they took a cut of the
booking so those differences were all
very important and then the inventory is
also what made it different as well
Airbnb pioneered didn't totally pioneer
but the other sites you mentioned didn't
do sharing where you're in the space at
the same time and that was the really
disruptive they do you mean by that
meaning like you rent out a room or you
might stay in someone's house but stay
in their second bedroom while they're
also oh I see so that was the kind of
crazy thing that was what everybody
thought really the Chery truly the
sharing economy even though it's paying
so it's it's right not exactly sharing
but but sharing the space was very new
and disruptive but all those things are
also what made it really appealing to
Millennials which at the time was really
unclaimed by the hospitality industry
and obviously as we know an enormous
market and they really seized on the
idea that first of all it was cheap I
mean that is the number one thing when
you're when you're sharing a property
like that the price is better and they
also liked that it was sort of this
counter cultural or anti corporate
adventurous you know authentic every
property's different I mean all these
things it was a sort of new way to
travel that really really caught on
among Millennials and plays into a whole
sort of artisanal culture local that we
all crave we all crave it's also they
like that it's not Millennials not to
treat them with a broad brush but
there's a sort of distrust or dislike
for anything to corporate and it was at
a time when I think even the hospitality
industry itself would say that things
had become so commoditized and so
consistent that was what they had strive
for for so long offer the same thing but
that didn't that wasn't exactly what
Millennials were looking for so I'm
gonna ask one more question and then
open it up to you and we'll go back and
forth I have some more questions for Lee
but we want to make this a a group
interview my favorite chapter in your
book I think is the chapter about what
Bryan and the others but mainly Bryan
learned from his mentors and I think it
was John Donahoe the former
CEO of eBay who said Brian is a learning
machine yeah learning animal learning
animal learning animal so talk about
some of the people the sort of iconic
business builders who Brian asked for
help yeah so this is interesting I mean
so again these three had no real
experience running a company of this
size Joe and Nate had run tried to get
their own businesses off the ground but
Brian didn't really know he didn't know
what a slide deck was he didn't know
what angel investors were somebody said
oh you've got to meet with these angels
and he said these people here are crazy
they believe in angels outside he was he
didn't know what the word entrepreneur
was he grew up in upstate New York and
you know he says this all the time
entrepreneur was like Bob's pizza shop
it wasn't he just didn't know anything
about anything and he knew that he knew
that he didn't know anything and he just
said I have to and there was no time
because as soon as they were off as soon
as they started to turn the numbers
around got their first investment from
Sequoia and the the growth took off from
there it's like until today it just
hasn't slowed down and so there was no
time to learn in any of the traditional
ways taking some night classes or going
to an executive mba or even just you
know sitting down and getting some
tutoring i don't know so he basically he
came up with this strategy called going
to the source and he told me about this
he said if you had to learn everything
there was to know about a topic and you
didn't have that much time what would
you do and I said well I would read
everything I could or he said yeah but
what if you only had one hour and his
point was spend most of your time
identifying the single best person for
whatever that topic is and then go right
to that person and ask them and so he by
that point had also had access to some
of the top minds in South Silicon Valley
so he was able to go to people like
Johnny I've for design from Apple or
Mark Zuckerberg or surely what did he
alert so what names some of these people
what did he learn from X & Y & Z well
let's see from from Reed Hoffman the
founder co-founder of LinkedIn
one of the early investors he learned
about growing and scaling a marketplace
business because LinkedIn is very much a
marketplace and Airbnb is and it's not a
core a marketplace business from from
from a lot of the venture capitalists he
learned sort of kind of everything but
he went to for example George Tenet who
used to run the CIA he went to him to
talk about culture because he thought
who better to talk about culture than
then somebody who ran an organization
where basically everyone's a spy and
doesn't trust each other and he took a
lot out from from George Tenet he told
him the importance of sort of walking
around the office and rewarding people
saying hey you did a good job writing
notes to people things like that
he learned a lot from John Donahoe
actually from eBay and they learned from
each other they had this sort of reverse
mentoring thing going on I mean he went
to Omaha talked to one boys Omaha talked
to Warren Buffett and from Warren he
learned from Warren he learned really
just he learned that it's really
important to sort of remove yourself
from all the noise he was really struck
that Warren Buffett just sits in his
office in Omaha and he just reads all
day long and he just he doesn't get
wrapped up in things and he just sort of
thinks big picture but that was a really
incredible meeting at the airport he
went back and he wrote like a 4,000 word
memo to send to his executive team about
this he's really interest that kind of
sharing these you see he writes these
Sunday night emails to the whole company
that are always on a different theme and
he actually wrote one about this whole
philosophy of going to the source and
sources versus mentors and there's a
slight difference but you know at one
point I asked one of their investors who
was telling me about how special this
was about Bryan and I said you know he's
in a pretty privileged spot you know if
I could pick up the phone and call Mark
Zuckerberg I'm sure I would have a lot
of good ideas too I mean or just I would
you know he's got this privilege of
being able to call up all these a list
the a list of the a list of Silicon
Valley and this person said to me you
know yes that's true but a lot of these
entrepreneurs have that same access and
have that same privilege and they don't
make the most of it and they don't they
don't use it and they don't even if
they don't necessarily see the results
of scaling I mean that's a word that's
used over and over in Silicon Valley do
you scale with the company and that was
the goal for these three founders could
they scale with the company the company
was going growing so fast could they
grow with it and I mean I don't think
there's any doubt that Brian Chesky is a
really great example on how to scale as
a CEO because going from where he was to
where he is now is a journey that I
don't think we've really ever seen
before
possibly in business because it wasn't
until this current wave of Silicon
Valley that somebody like that could
even be in a position to start a company
I mean in the in the old days you know
you'd have to go through all the
traditional channels right right who has
a question Dale and if you if you're
comfortable please identify yourself
wait for the wait for the mic all right
you want us to I think you we should go
over here correct yes Dale if you
wouldn't mind going over going over oh
yes
work okay so glad you're here Lee thank
you
I wondered you were saying he launched
three times so what was the moment after
the three times what were the moment of
traction of where it grabbed hold what
were the elements of that where it
turned around good question so the third
time that they launched was at the 2008
Democratic National Convention in Denver
and there was a housing shortage hotel
shortage and it was a big deal and they
saw their moment and they ended up
getting a lot of press and they got I
think 800 listings they got either
listings out there and they got some
business but after that it flatlined
again and they they realized that if
there's a convention every week we're
great but there isn't and so we don't
have a sustainable business so then they
had this idea where they would they did
a marketing gimmick where they created a
fictitious brands of cereal because they
wanted to pitch themselves as air bed
and breakfast was the name of the
company then and they did this whole
thing where they made these two cereals
captain captain McCain's over John
McCain and Obama owes for Obama and they
were cheeky
funny and quirky and very RISD and they
sold them for $40 of boxes collector's
editions and they seated them to the
press and they thought the press would
like that and they were right the press
ate it up and they ended up making
$30,000 from the cereal now that didn't
turn the company around in fact Brian
Chesky his mother called him at one
point and said I don't get it are you a
cereal company yeah and he didn't know
how to answer that question and that was
the most depressing thing because
technically they were making a lot more
money on the cereals and they were on
the business but ultimately one of their
advisors said you guys have to go apply
for Y Combinator which is an accelerator
program in Silicon Valley it's very
highly regarded and the three founders
said but we launched we've been written
up on TechCrunch we don't need to go to
Y Combinator and he looked at them
Michael Seibel and he said you guys are
dying you have to go to Y Combinator so
going to Y Combinator gave them and it
was the cereal that got them into Y
Combinator because Paul Graham who ran a
Y Combinator at the time and who's very
tough critic he didn't think it was a
good idea either he said what's wrong
with people they actually stay in
people's homes that's crazy but on the
way out they happen to mention that they
sold all this cereal and he said what he
said if you can convince people to buy
cereal for $40 a box you can probably
convince people to sleep in other
people's air mattresses so but then it
was really the advice that he gave them
once they were in which was go to your
users and shower them with love they
didn't have many users but the ones they
have were all here in New York and they
didn't even think about doing that
coming to visit their users here and
they literally sat with them for hours
on end and watched them use their
product they realized that they didn't
know how to post photos very well they
didn't know how to write listings in a
way that made them appealing so they
just sat with them and helped them
merchandize their listings in a better
way and dress them up and gusting them
up a little bit and doing that they saw
their numbers after a few weeks
double-double from a very low base but
that's what turned the numbers around
from there was still a very long journey
but that's what sort of that's when the
kind of the turning point hit and then
again when Sequoia came calling and
wrote the much
for 585 thousand dollars after everyone
said no so ah Mary alright so I have to
go over here right alright so Lee you
point out that home away and so the
other competitors are a more vacation
oriented play whereas Airbnb has picked
cities well it's more challenging in
cities so you've got the hotel industry
isn't happy with air and B&B people who
live in apartments don't really like
that some random persons across the hall
and then a random person so are they
going to in your opinion knowing the
leaders and so forth are they going to
be able to weather those kinds of
challenges so that's a great question so
anyone who reads the headlines knows
that there's been a tremendous amount of
pushback against Airbnb in particular
all over the world in many places it's
calmed down but in particular here in
New York City New York City and San
Francisco are the two toughest markets
and in the states and that's because it
is illegal here it is illegal not all of
the business it is illegal to rent out
your home for less than 30 days when
you're not there and it's only if you
have live in an apartment building it's
okay if you live in a house but and they
came in anyway and they grew and grew
and grew and that had a lot of people
challenged and not happy and I think and
they did a big ad campaign right they do
yeah they've done a bunch of ad
campaigns yeah so this is something they
were not totally prepared for you know
again just kind of being a little bit
naive to everything and the bigger
Airbnb a god of course the more the push
the pushback has the stronger it's
gotten and every city is has its
different issues here in New York it's a
lot of it's a big Center for the hotel
industry and the hotel Union is a very
powerful powerful force unions in
general are there's a lot of stories
written about how they're on the decline
but the hotel union is not and not in
New York City and so there's been a lot
of pushback and so I think that the you
know the consumer wants Airbnb and so
even the hotel industry knows that they
know that this
is touched on something that is working
but the hotel industry also says hey
you're you're able to get away with you
know you're making so much money because
you don't have to you know outfit you
know it bada compliant you don't have to
have sprinklers in it you don't have to
adhere to any of the same rules that
we're forced to adhere to and so they
just don't think it's a level playing
field and they're also for a long time
has been criticism that Airbnb there are
people that use it to operate illegal
hotels
so take housing and use it only for
Airbnb there is some of that on the site
they say they don't want it there's a
lot less than there used to be but in
the beginning there was a lot of that
activity so it has been a ongoing drama
and the drama continues I think that
everyone kind of recognizes that Airbnb
is here to stay and home-sharing in
general because technically the other
sites are now getting into cities as
well but it has been a huge headwind for
them we're gonna go to the back yes sir
come on down come on down
Oh Brad Guzan wrecking we don't really
know every single person we are I'm Brad
Grossman I'm the CEO and founder of
zeitgeist
following Brian on Instagram and social
and Twitter and he's been talking a lot
about this United Airlines debacle and
he keeps asking questions like if you
were to disrupt the airline industry
what would you do or if you had the
perfect flying experience what would you
do just because you cover so many
different industries and because of what
you do do you think the airline industry
is disruptive oh well Brian Chesky
definitely does and he wants to do it
absolutely I think it is I it's a
horrible experience so there was this
huge united crisis this week that we all
saw the top story every single day this
week and Airbnb has last November they
did a big launch of expanding into new
businesses including offering
on-the-ground experiences restaurant
reservations concert tickets and teas
that soon they're going to be doing
something involving flights and now that
and Brian Chesky has sort been hinting
at this for a while and he's looking at
this the same way he looks at either you
know anything I mean way design can be a
solution for any problem you know so
when they even with the regulation
regulation stuff well we have how do we
design our way out of this that's how he
and Joe Gebbia were trained so he's
looking at this exactly like that what
if what if and he has said this what if
flying were the best part of the trip
not the worst part of the trip what if
the plane felt more like a home so you
can sort of see where he's going but
he's been using Twitter to sort of reach
out and say what do people think we
should do what if you could imagine the
best kind of flying experience what
would it be
and he's also said that he's a little
bit disappointed with what people are
suggesting because they're not thinking
big enough
so I mean as a person of Fortune and
Patty maybe you'd agree do you think the
airline industry it's a very complicated
industry and it's an industry I mean
Warren Buffett has said he wouldn't
near the airline industry but he owns
buddy owns NetJets right okay maybe
commercial aviation that's true that's
true so but it's that would be the best
buying experience going private oh well
right but it's so bad and it's so
important that absolutely with enough
you know time and money and the right
idea I think it's easily disrupted but
one of the things this is fascinating to
me and I did not know that Brian is is
tweeting about this and it's very
interesting and I'm trying to imagine
and I'm wondering if you know more than
you're saying about how he might disrupt
the airline industry
do you know anymore I don't we didn't
really talk about this when I was
reporting the book and I've talked about
it with him a little bit but we haven't
gotten really specific I mean I actually
now that this has happened I'm gonna try
to find out whatever I can I well I mean
what strikes me though is one of the
things that is so interesting one of the
many things that's so interesting about
Airbnb versus uber is that you have this
in the book that Airbnb has spent so far
since its launch about 300 million total
and uber spent 330 lost 3 billion yeah
last year oh oh uber oh yeah
uber spent 1.2 billion in the first half
of 2016 right okay so Airbnb has a 31 or
30 plus billion dollar valuation now on
what's ubers valuation now 60 something
ok might be over 6 era but the fact is
the point the point here is that uber
has gotten to this size of 30 30 billion
dollar valuation by not spending a lot
of money this is not a baby if they're
being baby this is not a really capital
intensive business when you're talk
about airline suddenly you're talking
about major capital yeah that's why I
really I'm wondering what exactly
they've got up their sleeve and I
wouldn't be surprised if it I don't
think they're gonna do something this
year or next year I think you know yeah
I don't know but they've clearly had
discussions about I mean he knows his
tweets if you look at his tweets and
he's somebody will suggest something
he's already looked at that you know
he's he's he's out there he's
investigating so dealing with crises
which Airbnb has done a lot thanks Brad
and this relates to your question but
this disastrous response by by United so
Airbnb learned very early on I think it
was 2011 the ransacking of that one
property and talk about how Brian at
with the help of Marc Andreessen
responded to that because that's very
instructive it is and actually there's
there's very specific parallels to the
United situation as well so in 2011 a
woman who would have would have been
like Airbnb 'he's perfect central
casting host she had a blog where she
wrote about how much she loved sharing
her home she loved this particular sunny
corner for apartment and sharing it with
other people I mean it was like perfect
because they really loved to get all you
know lovey dovey like that and and she
was she rented at her house came back
and it was destroyed so violently like
beyond what you could even imagine and
it turned out that it was like crystal
meth heads who had gotten in and just
made a disaster out of her apartment
broke into her safe took her
grandmother's jewelry ruined her birth
certificate I mean there was like
substances everywhere it was horrible
and they had not really been prepared
for this this also confirmed everyone's
worst existing suspicions about what was
going to happen on an air B&B and they
came out and they got very defensive and
they said we're sorry you know this I
forget what the actual wording was but
it was just a this isn't our fault you
know it was just defensive and then it
got worse it just same thing like this
week it just got worse and worse and
worse and they were reeling they were
they had people flying in from all over
the country
these kind of customer service people
come in and slept in air mattresses on
the floor of the company's headquarters
it took a couple weeks to get through
this but in those few days where it was
really escalating out of control Marc
Andreessen was a brand-new investor at
the time they had just closed their
first mega round which valued them at
one point something billion dollars and
a lot of people thought that that's why
this story got leaked because people
were a little oh gosh look at them
they're so big for their britches and
this was actually had happened a month
prior and the woman had wrote it but
nobody noticed and so some suddenly it
was in the spotlight and Brian decided
after much consternation and thinking
that the right thing to do was to own
own this and come out and say they also
didn't have they didn't they probably
didn't have the right advisors
internally either but he came out and
took full ownership a few days later and
said this isn't right we're gonna work
to make this right and they started this
guarantee that was gonna be $5,000 but
Marc Andreessen added a zero the night
before as he was getting ready to send
the letter and he said I'm gonna make he
made two changes one was that you had to
have a police report because he didn't
want people to be able to just file and
not have a legitimate claim and he added
a zero to the number and Brian was like
we can't afford that what if this
happens all the time and he said you've
got to do it you've got to go big and
they did that and then ever since that
the company add a zero is sort of you a
euphemism for like I think a lot bigger
than whatever is right in front of you
and that guarantee is now a million
dollars there's a lot of extinct that
are excluded in it but that was the
basically the impetus for them to create
they didn't really have what they have
now which is they call the trust and
safety department which deals with
crises because it's not just one I mean
these things still have a department
it's a big department and these things
still do happen I mean there's a story
in my book of something it wasn't a
ransacking like that but it was a
fraudulent somebody rented out her home
to what she thought was a party for some
golfers during a golf tournament that
we're working with Golf Digest and it
was a ticketed hip-hop party for 400
youth you know people that were like 18
to 25 with DJs
cabañas and tickets that were sold on an
event break in a wealthy suburb in New
Jersey so this stuff happens even this
happens because you can't they can't
they don't interview every single person
that's using the site and there are bad
people out there but they did learn from
that crisis and the parallel to the
Oscar Munoz CEO of United Airlines he
said the wrong thing
people just double down and got crazy
because he he he literally I mean we all
saw what he said he said were real
common sorry we had to re accommodate
and he was belligerent or whatever then
he came out and took ownership but it
doesn't seem to be working it doesn't
seem to be quieting it down at all so
it'll be interesting to see because
interview in these case it did work they
did kind of quell it with that second
response and now every time they've had
subsequent subsequent crisis crises
which they have had a lot they they have
taken ownership pretty quickly so I
think they learned from that and they
say this whatever whenever something bad
happens there's the way you deal with it
but there's also you have to learn from
it you have to take a learning from it
otherwise you know it's just going to
happen again right right yes hi Richard
xxx my question for you is on the
disrupting not of the industry but of
sort of the culture and the way that
people think about lodging on a
go-forward basis and not necessarily our
generation that's sitting in this room
listening to this but like my kids and
so on what do you think
and what does Airbnb think the future of
lodging looks like is 12-month leases
for people that rent like is that the
standard or do people start living
slightly more pneumatically and
seasonally and quarterly or what do we
think bigger picture way down the road
yeah that's a great question and and
they are studying Joe Gebbia in
particular is studying long term housing
I mean they they believe that there's
going to be more apartments that are
designed from the ground up to be shared
that millenials and young renters want
to move into a place where they know
they're gonna have an income stream and
they're trying to pitch to landlords
this is better for you guys because you
know that your tenants are going to be
able to pay their rent but in the future
they think that housing is going to be
shared
and they think that you know long-term
leases are I don't know we didn't talk
about this a ton but they think that you
know that is the way of the future I
mean home sharing or being able to
monetize wherever you're living and then
what he did say something about this but
like he thinks that the era of mass
production is over he thinks that
there's all these big seismic shifts
that are coming but I do think that the
hotel industry is seeing a future in
this also and that's probably the
biggest evidence that there is something
here that is going to be a pretty long
lasting change in terms of hospitality
and a lot of people a lot of the hotel
companies are starting to get into home
sharing many of them have been doing it
before anyway but it's it's a big area
of growth and many people foresee a
future where you can check into a hotel
and a front desk and they give you your
keys and your keys or to an apartment
that's around the corner
there's many startups in this field a
lot of the big companies are looking at
it and getting into it and so that's
sort of in hospitality there definitely
is going to be a lot of changes yeah I
would say I haven't thought about this a
little bit we're likely to see
fundamental shifts in the way that
people think about where they live and
how they live and so if you think about
why people live where they tend to live
we used to be an agrarian society so you
live near the farm now then we move it
into services and so you live near the
investment bank or the law firm or
whatever now it's all about creative and
so on it so we see a lot of people that
do content and podcasts and they just
live wherever they want
not everybody you know obviously people
with kids in schools and so on have
reasons to be settled but and you also
start to see it in the commercial space
so companies like we work you know I
used to have a ten year lease on a
building for my business and now I move
to we work and with 30 days I can size
up
I can size down I can move across the
street I can move across the country
like the flexibility is so remarkable do
you think I'm ever gonna sign a 10-year
lease
I mean in commercial that's absolutely
very disruptive and I think that that's
a that is no the answer maybe no but I
do think it when you talk
the concept of home I mean home is such
an emotional it's our safe space it's
our I don't think we're all going to be
moving around all the time although
there is a couple in my book where I
wrote about who retired four years ago
on Airbnb and then the past four years
they every ten days they go to a
different Airbnb all across Europe I
mean I interviewed them they were in
Croatia they emailed me a few months ago
they're in South Africa they've stated
130 Airbnb s they sold their house and
they don't know when they're gonna stop
and how much do they spend a year doing
this they spend they figured out they
spend about ten to fifteen percent more
than they would spend if they were just
living in Seattle but they're very
frugal and they're very clear that
they're not on vacation they do the
exact same things that they would do if
they were retired in Seattle they play
Scrabble at night they cook every meal
they're just doing it in other people's
homes instead of senior nomads they have
a website senior nomads calm yeah yeah
yes I wonder if I could pass my
microphone no maybe not
thank you okay Ellen Chow I am wok
management advisor that's Merrill but I
was a CFO of high-tech industry so I was
quite familiar with the CEO in this she
said I first of all is that well we're
talking about the the difference between
the Airbnb and uber I think Airbnb is
doing great job but also Oprah has this
insurance requirement that Airbnb
doesn't have quite yeah so that keeps in
mind insurance for the drivers yes and
the clock right so basically Airbnb yes
homeowners need to have insurance but
seriously when we check in to Airbnb
we're not asking for the Hat and nobody
is so that that has a lot to do with it
absolutely my question really is is
there any specific regulation for or
rules say from Airbnb to require all the
home shares to follow for example if I
want to check into a shortened or
Marriott or Hilton I know exactly what
kind of sender I could stay up to write
certain type of things I can expect but
Airbnb is doing anything like that no I
mean it's it's it's public homes and for
public consumption it's private homes
for public consumption and so you cannot
make someone do something I mean it is
you know if somebody's private home they
can do whatever they want they have
started I mean many years ago they
brought on a guy named chip Conley who
came from the hospitality industry and
they really decided they wanted to
double down on really hot on hospitality
because there was a point where somebody
said people were telling the music I
should do office space you should share
stairmasters any fixed asset that
someone has they should make the list on
Airbnb they said no we're gonna double
down on hospitality they brought them in
and one of the things he did was to try
to put in standards and there's a lot of
resources on the website I mean if you
are hosting someone in your home and
you're listing your your place up on the
site you want to earn money you want to
do to increase the odds of getting
people bucking
and so you're well advised to kind of
follow their advice and clean the sheets
and put some flowers in the room and you
know spruce the place up and maybe offer
a glass of wine or a snack or coffee or
just it asks everybody to really put on
their inner innkeeper hat you know and
really like you know cuz people do and
get a good rating or else you're not
gonna get more business I mean that's
the that's the check and bow that's what
they thought was gonna solve all these
problems that you know this is a natural
system that will you know just kind of
weed out anyone who doesn't do the right
thing will just not get that much
business and that basically works
there's but there's a lot of great
inflation on Airbnb reviews because
everybody feels like they don't really
want to you just stayed in this person's
place there's a social interaction you
don't want to criticize them so there's
a way to do it without making it public
but the reviews they would say are key
to keeping everyone you know keeping the
bar high but everyone's gonna have a
different level of service and you can
tell that in the listing and you can
tell when there's a property there where
the host goes above and beyond I mean
somebody I talked to in Staten Island he
goes and picks people up at JFK Airport
and you know brings them back and loves
it but some people it's very clear if
you're on your own this is just a place
to stay for the night you know there's
all kinds of levels of everything and
you just have to be good about looking
for what you want and seeing a place
that you think meets the criteria for
what you're looking for great thank you
one more question quickly other than
what Mary just some just stated what is
the toughest issue the Airbnb you think
is facing right now I think the
regulatory pushback is a lot of it I
don't think they would say that they
think that they have that pretty under
control but I think that's a that's a
big deal it's certainly going to be a
big deal when the company goes public
investors are going to want to know is
this a risk or not I also think the
chances that something can go very wrong
it's always out there I mean any night
something really bad could happen
New Year's Eve there were two million
people staying in Airbnb listings around
the world the chances that one of them
something's going to go really bad
whether it's an axe
because somebody didn't have a railing
somewhere they've had that they've seen
all of this but they could see it more I
mean
we're gonna see bad things happen at an
Airbnb it's gonna be in the headlines I
mean I have said you know it's like
whatever happens in hotels is also gonna
happen on Airbnb at this point I mean
there might be a terrorist plot that's
hatched in the Airbnb it's possible I
mean all of this stuff is just gonna go
they do their best they can and
statistically all this stuff it's very
very low but I think that's probably one
of the biggest challenges for them and
then things they don't expect like they
had a problem with discrimination last
summer that was a huge crisis for the
company because their whole mission is
all about belonging their mission
statement is anyone can belong anywhere
and this is the exact opposite of that
and that also came out of the blue for
them although many people said it
shouldn't have come out of the blue and
they agreed with that so there's a lot
of challenges which is why it's so
amazing that this company has gotten so
far and why it's so incredible that 160
million trips have been taken on this
thing that everyone thought was totally
nuts
you're a close observer of uber and you
know Travis and I'm curious whether you
think that there are any lessons that
uber could learn from Airbnb I think
there's a lot of lessons I don't know
Travis I met him once actually met him
at the famous dinner about uber dinner
I remember that that's why I'm thinking
I don't I don't really know him I don't
I don't follow them that closely other
than just being a business journalist
and following what's going on and
studying this obviously this sharing
economy universe oh gosh I mean they're
so different these two companies they're
often lumped into the same bucket
because they're both considered pioneers
of the sharing economy but they're their
business models are different their
losses are very different because their
business models are different and they
their cultures could not be more
different
I mean Airbnb is the culture is so kind
of kumbaya it's almost like it's so over
the top it's like people drink kool-aid
there they're obsessed with this mission
of belonging they actually have this
they have these 48 taps in their kitchen
in their cafeteria because it's like no
waste anywhere and so it's all on tap
and they have this drink that is like a
red
it's called rent B&B it's like an
in-house Red Bull it's made with
artisanal high Disqus and all this stuff
so it literally looks like you're
drinking kool-aid what you're drinking
it but but they're very proud of their
culture and rightly so it's it's people
really like to work there they've won
all these awards for it it's growing it
when they become such a bigger company
has been a challenge but it's still
really good culture ubers culture is
we're seeing it we're seeing it play out
and I think that stuff starts at the top
I think Travis kalanick is an aggressive
ruthless you know kind of I mean
everything we read about him I don't
think you can I don't think the stories
are far from the truth they can't be and
the lessons to be learned I think that
that's a really good question well he's
looking for a number two supposedly I
think that you just you can't just say
things you have to really like believe
them and you have to it's all about
behavior and you have to learn from
other people I mean I think that Brian
Chesky has done that so well and you
can't be a know-it-all right you can't
be a know-it-all you you have to own up
to things when they're wrong and bad
I do think Airbnb has been good about
that I it took over a long time to open
up and for Travis to say that I need
help as a leader and I'm gonna go get
that help I think the biggest lesson
would be go get the help the way Chesky
got that help go and interview and sit
down with all these he's got access to
the top names to go sit down with them
and ask them what could I do better you
know how come this is happening here
what break it down is it me I mean you
know obviously it is and so he needs
this I mean he needs leadership help but
he should go get it I mean we'll wait
and see you they don't know when the
announcements gonna come as to who he's
hiring as it's number two but it's not
just its it's top to bottom it has to be
everywhere and you can't just you know I
remember when they hired the guy from
Target it was like we're gonna tell
stories you know and you can't you can't
just hire someone - the guy from Target
Scott right he left but you can't just
say you're gonna do these things you
have to really believe it and I think
Luber really believes it one
to win and that's what we're seeing it's
winning it's done at all cost it's done
a tremendous amount it is I mean I have
you know during my book deadline I spent
a lot of time in uber and lyft I mean
cuz I had no time you can push a button
in a car will come I mean he's one in a
lot of ways but it is all all kind of
everything is at stake right now because
of because of these other things right
right who else has a question yes Tony
you want to come up all right Tony
Haskell pleasure being here thank you hi
Tony this is more of a 30,000 foot
question relative to kind of your
experience because he obviously
interviewed many many entrepreneurs over
the years but there's a new book coming
out on on business schools and I'm just
wondering and maybe this is a self
answering question but do you feel like
just giving Brian's story and Zuckerberg
story and and all the rest of these mega
entrepreneurs that Business School is
today the top ones are stifling the
entrepreneurial spirit and what would
this story even would this company even
been blossoms given the rigor and their
kind of thinking that are in today's
business schools relative to the the
background of the three founders of this
company that's a very good question
there's this book it's by Def Mac Donald
coming out soon about Harvard Business
School and really we have questioning
everything Tony just said as you said uh
you know this business is a classic
example
Airbnb of totally stumbling upon
something accidentally and I think some
of the best ideas in business over
centuries have have come into you know
come into being that way a necessity is
the mother of admit invention the total
opposite way is to hatch an idea in a
business school lab and you know there
are a certain classes from Harvard
Business School that have minted a lot
of these entrepreneurs a lot of them
were all in the same class like the
founders of blue apron the founders of
Birchbox
the founders of classpass they all came
out and sort of launched these
businesses but I do think sometimes in
business school
like okay we want to start a company
what should the idea be and it's sort of
reverse engineered and I think that the
best ideas happened the other way around
when there's a real need for them which
is why I think it's interesting
Airbnb is next businesses that's
launching they sort of develop to them
four years in the Airbnb lab and now
they're introducing them onto the
marketplace and it's very different from
when you just accidentally stumble upon
something and you know nobody who goes
to business school this is shouldn't say
nobody but business school isn't about
learning how to accidentally stumble
upon something it's about learning how
to meticulously plan something that's
going to be a success I'm a huge fan of
blue apron it's a huge success so it's
not like there's you know it's not there
can't be wonderful ideas that come out
of business school but we're seeing
another model by all means you had a
question yes you don't have to come over
my question was I heard about the
founding of Airbnb driving somewhere how
I made it and exactly what you were
saying I was thinking about the idea as
if someone pitched him you know and I
would think this is a bad idea because
of all the unknowns in that right and
it's once home so of and of course now
it's it's so successful but even now if
someone had pitched that idea to me if I
hadn't known about Airbnb I'd have said
this is this is a dangerous thing to do
but you said over new years there were 2
million people staying in Airbnb s what
would be the kind of thing and just to
play devil's advocate won't be the kind
of thing that could potentially bring
the Airbnb model crumbling well in the
beginning it was a terrible safety
incident and that incident in 2011
people thought that was the end of the
company even the people that work there
they're like this is it we're done like
we knew it was gonna end I mean I just
talked with somebody recently and they
said that they were like when is this we
know this can't go on forever like we
know that this is just something's gonna
be felis
and it didn't so so now I think the
company is too bit it's like too big to
fail it's if you know I don't know the
worst safety incident I don't know the
worst thing you could possibly think of
a mass murder in an Airbnb listing I
mean I don't know could that take the
company down a thirty billion dollars
and all these users I don't think so
because it's it's too many users it's
everywhere I mean 80% of its inventory
is outside the US only 20% of it is here
and so the other thing is it's no longer
reliant on any one market anymore so I
mean the discrimination crisis was was
pretty big but again I don't think I
could have taken the company down I
don't know that's a really good question
I'd love to know if anybody else has
thoughts on that if you could stand up
because there's a mic here that we need
to serve good change people's in like
impressions and consumers ability you
know desire to choose Airbnb and
regulations I think regulates would
change depending on what consumers want
ultimately I guess human rights those
issues could be a factor you know or if
it doesn't if it stops growing and not
as much as its investors need to satisfy
this valuation I mean it could enter
into business troubles I mean if
people's not travel or something like
that yeah I mean I know what he would
say he would say the thing that would
kill us is our culture and if people
stop feeling comfortable to suggest big
ideas I mean that's what I'm telling you
that's what he would say Lee what what
he would say that if we stop if the
culture suffers if the culture stops
being what it is and making it a place
where people feel comfortable to think
big so what are they gonna get into
beyond what they're in today what are
they in today besides home sharing well
they're into last November they launched
experiences so now when you travel you
can book and experience with a local
like here in Harlem you can go and tour
Spanish Harlem with a guy who grew up
there he'll show you where he learned to
rap he'll take you to his favorite
you know restaurant and all this stuff
and you can do that all over the world
you can book concert events Brian Chesky
thinks that intimate living room concert
and concert events are going to disrupt
the concert business and that's how
we're gonna see music he thinks that
this is going to be a new way for music
labels and artists to be discovered by
playing in someone's living room you are
going to be able to both ground
transportation you are going to be able
to if you need a crib on your trip you
can get that through Airbnb they want to
basically supply everything they already
are gonna offer services they've said
that you can have a chef come and
prepare a meal and you're listening you
can what else make a restaurant
reservation they don't do all this now I
know some of it is still being teased
flights and ground transportation are
still in the future and services
basically they also want you to be able
to use they want you to use Airbnb not
just when you're traveling but in your
home city so it's Friday night what am I
gonna do tonight let me look at Airbnb
he wants Airbnb to not be synonymous
with a place to stay he wants it to be
kind of a lifestyle thing do you think
this is a good idea I think it's a very
open question as to how this will all do
I mean we know this company for one
thing and one thing only and they've
done a very good job at totally
introducing something that have went
wondrously viral and changed travel we
don't know if these other things are
gonna when you look at the app now you
see experiences and what if I only want
to book a place to stay I don't
necessarily want to see the experiences
they say that they're doing well but
we'll see I mean they're trying to be an
end-to-end travel company and they want
to be you know the first online travel
company that reaches one hundred billion
dollars is what someone told me so we'll
see and flights I mean and who knows
what else there's an opportunity I said
strike while the iron's hot yeah that's
better why don't you come come over here
since you're in the front row Caicos
that I just put on Airbnb this January
it was on VRBO and flip key last year
and I have no problem renting
whatsoever it's a half a block from the
best beach in the world however this
year all of a sudden sales went weed I
mean not sales but bookings went way
down in my son who lives there said we
should put it on air bee and me
well instantly almost no rentals from
VRBO and flip key from a year ago which
no problem at all and now it's taken
over in fact it's changed the culture on
Turks and Caicos which is a high-end
island where it was really very
exclusive and very very little low
rental spaces that's all the biggest
list of hotels or condos now you can't
get along term rental on Turks and
Caicos if somebody's coming to be a chef
at the restaurant they have trouble
finding because everybody's taking their
home and turning it into a business and
and it's changed the whole culture of
Turks and Caicos and I thought well
that's like from one year to the next in
like a few months I saw like I'm Anna
Norman I think you can probably see it
more on a vacation spot like that and
you can't in a big city but it's
incredible well that's it you're talking
about changing the character because the
types of people that come and rent the
properties are different and you do see
that here in New York I mean you do see
that when people who live in we live on
top of each other here in New York City
and nobody wants a and I think the
neighbor issue is a bigger deal than the
safety issue in in cities because you're
having transient people come in using
the public spaces using the front lobby
in the public space of the building they
might not lock the door the right way
and they might not put the trash in the
right place they're on vacation you're
not you have to give a presentation
tomorrow morning and somebody next to
you is coming home you know drunk
because they're on vacation they're
having fun I mean I don't know we New
Yorkers are easily annoyed it's stuff
like that we're a little bit closer you
know and yeah a little bit more spread
out right but you know it's but still
it's it's an issue and whoo yeah I was
always resistant to putting it on
because for those reasons but I would
think you just get I mean I if I was
going to Turks and Caicos I would look
yeah we think you'd get and I don't know
maybe I'm not the kind of person he was
[Laughter]
I just didn't you know I was used to
looking it was used to listening and on
the other side and it seemed I and and
I'll tell you the difference which I
actually didn't like it first and then
now I actually prefer it but it would
take a lot longer to rent a place on the
others because there was a conversation
back and forth which in some way is very
good because you kind of get to know a
lot of times I would call up the person
if they preside and presented their
telephone number which often they did
and I would be able to get a feel and
they'd get a feel of me but in air B&B
they just say accept or reject and I and
you don't really get the same
communication with the person so you
have less you know right so I have one
one well and let's go ahead lay so you
do like Airbnb though you've filled your
house it's easier it's good I do think
there's a convergence though I think
everyone is starting to you the VRBO
people are starting to use Airbnb the
Airbnb people are starting to use the
VRBO and home away and it's much more so
this leads to should we buy the stuff
well no but what's what are your
expectations about when the IPO will
take place well they say and Brian
Chesky I interviewed him on stage for
the New York economic Club a few weeks
ago and asked him about this and he also
told me this in 2015 he considers
getting ready to go public a two-year
process and the reason you know and his
goal would be to be ready before you
want to go public so that you can then
pick your moment when the moment is
exactly right so he consider he said a
few weeks ago he considers them to be
halfway through that process they hired
a CFO in 2015 a new CFO he came from
Blackstone and so let's say they started
that me that would put us to next year
so I don't think they're going public
this year there were rumor
about that I don't think it yes I said
there's four reasons to go public
because you need the money because you
want to do M&A for a branding event and
for liquidity for shareholders and he
said it's a terrible idea to do it for a
branding event we don't need the money
we already are an acquirer they've
acquired companies and the only reason
to do it is liquidity and it sounds like
they are facing that issue both for
employees but really for investors
they've done a few events for employees
so I think it'll be 2018 it might be
later but they don't seem to be in a
rush it's hard to know but I wouldn't
put it I would say mid 2018 but maybe I
could be wrong I have one last question
it's personal I have never used Airbnb
I'm thinking about using it this summer
in in Mexico and you told me you'd give
me some advice so I might as well just
use this stage to ask for what is your
basic best advice for the first-time
user or any users really use the reviews
it's so obvious but it's the single best
way to like make sure you're gonna get
something that is close to what you want
the more reviews the better if something
somebody has a heavily trafficked
property that's a good sign that they
take it seriously they get a lot of
business and then anything that's
negative in a review just take it like
exponentially further it's like online
dating if someone says something hits
it's something you know that that's a
really big problem so just you know
really really read things clearly and
ask questions and look at the photos if
you don't see something if you don't see
a coffee maker ask about it
I'll ask about air conditioning because
you can't see what it feels like in the
in the place so just put your journalist
hat on and ask a lot of questions okay
that's not true you can ask questions
yeah you can message with the hosts yeah
mm-hmm yeah Thank You Lee this was
fascinating thank you everyone for a
quite enjoyed the book everyone the
Airbnb story by Lee Gallagher
[Music]